ja klar
was es geht sondern willkommen zu einer
neuen weiteren logischen folge zu halbe
games mit wer hätte es gedacht weil
dieser ansage dem lieben logo spieler
teams weiter games heute unter dem
zeichen tuma da habe ich leider nicht
wann mein arm über wird zu zweit sind
aber tun aber es hat immer noch einen
mehr quasi doppelt so viele mails wie
der one man army und du voll kleiner
ich bin nicht direkt hinter die welche
man von hier oben
ach so herunter springen ja wie du
meinst ich darf diese route schon
ungefähr ganzes leben leiser dem ich
geboren wurde was ist seitdem ich
geboren wurde und dafür eine aussage das
kannst du mir nicht sagen in zukunft auf
damit waffen für dich wenn du brauchst
ja ich habe auch im stein schwert ich
könnte in hollstadt nachgeben hier habe
ich hab ich den lauf nummer richtung
sand wurde ich in die andere richtung ja
wo wollen wir jetzt den st
wie willst du dann möglich wenn jeder
aufnahme zur wiederaufnahme schlechte
warum denn wieso war das ein schlechter
witz
jetzt stellt er sich moni und anschaffen
oder klasse oder den habe ich schon mal
da nehme ich mir zuerst weg genug ach du
scheiße wie sternen geflogen doch all
das war zehn blöcke wenn wir da zehn
blöcke weg
ja ich aber ich muss dich jetzt
angreifen weil
der gegend noch vor ist auch der name
klingt dann ohne hat sich jetzt ohne
ständig beginn der wert nicht schnell
wieder hinter habe
nein ich bin das ganze ganz andere ende
des strandes ok ja weiter erfolgten
einer mit brüste hast du bist gerade
eben ja ich hab nur in bregenz und und
schuhe diamant und eisenachs hatte hatte
diesmal aber er folgt dem anderen gerade
private und natürlich erst mal ehrlich
luthe gehört das zweite schiff da bin
ich gerade hat den strand ab alles klar
hier richtig
ich hab das und ich hab davon jeweils
gut aber irgendwie kann jeder jeder
kennt das ja aber auch nur bei pamela
anderson dicke dies hat die sich gerne
mal abstecken wollte nicht nur ja die
also die die die strand diese ok wird
uns das eis essen wie kriege wie kann
ich das jetzt noch das jetzt auch retten
also gar nicht mehr ist gestorben
keiner ist gestorben
ok ok leute zweierteam existenz jetzt
musst du baywatch machen du musst mich
retten ja gerne aber du wirst du ich hab
mein schwert laufen laufen laufen
richtung verdacht stand 27
alternativen wären sie decken ein
goldabbau reindrücken
komm zu mir sind die gut
ich habe ihm noch der antrag nicht
bekommen bis zum start ohne superstars
alter wie schadet der mitte gemacht
er hasst es auch der lief ganz normal
und hat mit lotte flack alter das ist
nicht normal was war das denn bestellt
er mich dann gesagt kann eure leute sie
können die kommentare schreiben das von
irgendwie zum glück nicht immer gefragt
was ich nachts im bett muss man hat ein
atomkrieg 44 und unter einer minute
dreißig ja wahrscheinlich war mit 15
freunden in der runde
die sind alle gelüftet ja genau
oder aber alle ihre eigene betten
zerstört als sie zugeben kann man das
geht nicht
ich bin auf falsche warum geht das nicht
dennoch keine waffe ich bin wieder da wo
grenzen auf getroffen
ich habe waffen eine waffe habe ich eine
waffe
ich bin beim sportsponsoring sich
konsums von ich muss nur durch schaffen
durch dieses gefühl hier läuft aber
jetzt sei klar was hier los sei wie ist
denn hier los
wie heißt du bist du noch in 2009 10
habe ich mich ab es ist ein dreierteam
ist so crazy sol gabetta genau die
folgen gerade danke ich gegen taktisch
perfekt nein ach was denn jetzt du bist
das mit minecraft 1950
darum kommt eine völlig richtig gesehen
hat laufen
keine sorge ich bin das menschliche
schutzschilde hast deine waffe du hast
ja ich hab ich dafür sollten den spec
ein bisschen abheben
da hast du aktuell und schulen jas nicht
da warst du nicht hinkommt einer yamaha
oder mich noch kann es alleine schaffen
falls ich lauf von der seite für seite
im ski alpin herzlich ein halbes
jahrzehnt ein halbes herz halbes
herzlich um weiterhin auf der seite bin
ich mache jetzt eine drehung jetzt eine
rasante um das haus war das knapp
was war das typen da vorne der sommer
war der juli zwölf jahre warte warte
kurz macht ich hab ja okay da machen
kaputt wenn du kannst ja jetzt alles
diamanten
okay ich habe einstein schwert bin froh
wenn ich habe jedoch reisen reisen schuh
drückt ich hab gesehen ist okay jetzt
nächste versuchte auf den darum durch
diese lege kommst du unter kommst du
denn dann können wir das häuschen
deckungsreihe mit der angel zu gehen
damit ich nicht versucht sagen ja genau
das was ich auf jeden fall noch mal
worauf noch mal zurückkommen wollte ich
hab jetzt gestern den neuen pc bestellt
ok hab ihm mitgegeben der wird
wahrscheinlich versuchen sein gold apfel
zu essen ich schaff das nicht mehr wenn
er jetzt überall dafür dass war die
schnell den weg ab ja dafür perfekt den
gegner den hammer heute gibt uns die
leute gefordert den frist ich mir den
haben stirbt mit erstem leben kommt ein
paar sehr gut eur hier leute ich hab den
neuen pc bestellt und ich wollte euch
einfach nur mal kurz erzählen was der
alles so drauf hat und zwar hat das teil
einen ich hab's schon mal gesagt ich
fast nur kurz noch zusammen so als
update video und zwar hat er nie 4097
prozessor vier mal 3,6 ghz der hat
bosnische entfällt hier dann gehe ich
doch kein ständig brauche habe ich auch
der hat ein hat sechs gigabyte
arbeitsspeicher hat eine gtx 760 das ist
ziemlich gut und es gibt noch dazu zu
sagen ja 120 überlässt sich die ein
terabyte festplatte habe ich ja schon
mal gesagt ein video noch für alle die
ich jetzt mal nicht noch nicht
mitbekommen hatten
hier nochmal so dass jetzt auch alle
wissen und wissen auf was sie sich
freuen dürfen was ich mich freuen darf
denn ich sage euch wenn der pc da ist
dann hunderte frames ländern in drei
minuten und so weiter ich weiß schon wie
das ist von max ähnlichen rechner nur
das denn ein bisschen mehr ram hat
glaube ich da machen oder
ich glaube wir dürfen ziemlich ähnlichen
rechner haben das ist ein dreierteam
ding raus rein raus
okay okay okay es tut mit freeman army
alter die kassieren weg weg director ich
hab ich doch direkter
glaub ich hab eigentlich am pult echt
junge wie viele jetzt hast du verloren
ich habe dreieinhalb verloren einfach
drei leute zerlegt läuft bei uns
brauchst du noch irgendwas alter mann
ich habe 23 feile feuerzeug und eisen
stört dieses eine thema ja schon mal
wiederum ergriffen
der halter tui da kann man keine league
im beruf
okay ich gehe mal auf ex kieler hdw geht
auf eskil ein express sie gerade
ein pro fordert alles klar
ja genau treibt immer darum ich werde
dann alles klar wir haben weggehauen ist
natürlich heftig schwer dagegen zu
bestehen da jetzt gegen zwei meter
antreten muss aber ist halt team ist
gene und damit sind wir schon unsere
alten dieser super leon dennoch
angezeigt würde ich muss nicht dass ich
muss auch kurz wegen ich bin drei zwei
eins meins guckt
nein ich hab gelassen für dich ja 17
hörst du 37 kann gibt 19
die hälfte nein nicht so viel
ja und dann heute die hast genau machen
wir los 32 1 alles klar
noch mehr machen
es wurde heute übrigens von meinen
wirtschaft ich habe nur noch drei herzen
oh nein ich bin ja was du kita ich habe
normal weiter
guckt euch das an ages das ist logo
entscheidet ihr unterläuft weg und
feiner schotter wird geblockt er wird
gebloggt hat es gesehen der fall wurde
geblockt oh mein gott der fall wurde
geblockt doch lucky bessert alter ist
scheiße wenn man tot ist dann kann man
einfach nicht mehr die schönen sachen
des lebens genießen
komm jetzt ich hasse diese leute die
dämme weggelaufen als ständig stehe ich
jetzt
du hast entscheidet die rein live
sessions richtig 3 erzielte das 3 h
es bringt er anstellt junge du hast so
viel schaden gedealt alter desto mehr zu
herzen
ich habe mir ja klar
genau machen weiß nicht ob er genug
naja leute bald geht's weiter bald ist
es geschenkt da mein persönliches
geschenk der neue pc dann kann ich mich
auch wieder noch mehr freuen darauf
wieder zu machen weil dann geht's wieder
schnell und dann kann ich auch viel
besser zocken euch dann noch wie flüssig
spielen kann und es werden goldene
zeiten anbrechen
das euch jetzt kann ich jetzt noch den
logo abchecken er ist in der
beschreibung und gucken was er sonst im
deathmatch macht ob er sich sonst auch
mal versteckt hiermit entscheidet der
erste satz macht und natürlich ein
leichter lassen einen kommentar
schreiben ihr wissen
ist und wenn sie mal von nächsten video
wieder dazu